what you are
um so let me just ask
um
for almost 20 years now what has been
the biggest revolution
development during that
but i also believe just for the uh for
gaming in general uh the focus on
accessibility
and um you know the advances that have
been made there
uh is has been the biggest change that
i've seen over
the past 20 years
felix back in august we spoke about the
impact of covet
on indie development now that a couple
of months have passed do you believe the
way
the industry the industry has adapted
will have an impact like a lasting
impact on
game development i mean i guess i can
only speak for indie
uh i don't i mean i would invite the aaa
people to maybe chime in for triple a in
general but i think for indie it
definitely
will um you know i know a lot of small
studios that have gone
completely remote where they weren't
before and that's something that it's a
big commitment right and i think
um you know it's possible when you have
eight people or ten people to
keep that going and maybe even to see
the benefits of it and the downside of
it both right and to sort of weigh that
but i do think a lot of
different studios are opening up to the
concept of remote work and maybe even
working across time zones
in the ways that they weren't before um
which hopefully brings more
talent from more places in like
hopefully we're able to see that as a
good thing and start to bring in talent
from not just our
immediate you know city or neighborhood
we are able to sort of or or ask people
to move we're able to sort of reach
outside of that and see talent in other
places but
um we'll see i mean that's the that's
all the like uh
really positive version of what the
answer could be so i'm gonna stick with
that right now because
i think there are a lot of other answers
i could give but that one i'm hoping is
the thing that we take
from this is the ability to really
invite new talent in via via
flexibility yeah
yeah i would say somebody who works at a
studio who's gone totally remote
uh and has worked with teams from
different time zones before
like it's totally kind of
interchangeable at least from
my perspective and the teams i worked on
it's just like
uh what felix is saying i want to echo i
hope it's a really good opportunity for
people to not have to move to get good
jobs in
in games and stuff i feel like i can
only speak about this anecdotally but
like
on a broad scale there are so many
limits to uh getting into the games
industry i came from a city where it
wasn't very big and was having to fly to
sydney all the time
when i was in media to be able to talk
about this stuff and it's been very nice
to see
the steps we've taken in the direction
of having the industry be
um more accessible to a lot of different
people just by virtue of this happening
but
obviously like i definitely know this
from from talking to people in the
aaa space um that there are tremendous
challenges security challenges
uh definitely it's very very complicated
and i feel like it's like
everyone's been learning over the course
of the past 12 months how to make
video games remotely um which you know
we'll probably see
how much of an impact that has kind of
next year i feel like that probably had
a big impact on halo infinite
so definitely ups and downs but you're
absolutely right to lead with the
positive there that
this is something that um is is very
cool
for uh anyone who's felt like they can't
get into the industry because they don't
live in the right place so
that's a win yeah yeah i
actually think as somebody that's been
in the industry for so long
uh uh you know a positive has been kind
of like this shake-up where all of a
sudden
it's not routine i mean nobody will ever
say that making any single game is like
a routine but like you start to feel
like oh i know
here's where we are here here's where we
are here and for us
like in production we're at a spot was
very familiar to everybody and
all of a sudden this happens and we go
remote from home
and it's like all of a sudden we're
doing something
almost historical like we've never done
this before we've never shipped the game
while we work from home so it was a it
was actually kind of like
a good like wake up and you know a
reminder that we're always having to
grow
in games it's that's actually the thing
that brings us to it
and i think we're really fortunate too
in that we can be an entertainment
industry where
we don't necessarily need to be sitting
next to another person to continue our
job like i have friends that work in la
in
you know tv and other media forms and
they've been hit really hard and you
know i think for us in the game industry
we're super lucky that
we're already used to working with
technology used to communicating over
the internet and being close in that
regard has really helped us
create the games in a different kind of
space also they're selling so well
there is something that feels a little
bit weird about like
animal crossing did so well this year
like
i mean i mean even the game we're
playing right now yeah
right well yeah i think that's actually
an interesting point too is that i think
that
we just named animal crossing and among
us like those are both social games and
i think that i at least anecdotally have
turned a lot more to social games and
multiplayer games than i normally do
like i would almost completely play
single player experiences and now it's
just like
i absolutely look forward to having like
even just the interaction of
knowing that there's another human
behind the avatar moving in across the
screen you know
it's big yeah yeah i think i've never
played
this much multiplayer games
in my life i think i used to be a loner
like i loved
going on my own pace but now i want to
play
every single multiplayer there is
like hang out and have friends with me
and also like from the content creation
side of things like i mean for us
also like discovering games like this
where you can actually like
um share with an audience or share with
other content creators has been amazing
and i think even though we had those
options before
the pandemic this has actually like
pushed us toward a lot of
experiences that we might have looked
over
i will not read it out loud yeah
[Laughter]
i will find where to put it yes i did
i'm like a toddler right like i always
read things a lot of times
i'm that guy in the car that's always
reading signs you know
like it would be a fun thing to say out
loud
[Laughter]
cross i actually don't understand how
alana can like
do two streams at the time like i just i
just went to your channel and
it's like you're having an actual stream
yeah
it's down uh well i'm also streaming on
on twitch and on youtube um
um and it basically like people are like
how do you manage those chats but it
just
combines them all in one chat so to me
it just looks like one
that's cool they are complaining that i
need to increase my voice volume though
so i've been working on figuring out how
to do that for the loss
go ahead and go ahead i'm too quiet so
we are playing on a map that i've never
played before
just f watch oh same
okay
more chaotic better yeah let's level the
playing field
okay
it's getting mad at us now i was just
gonna
let's make it a room code that's not as
fun to say
out loud okay i'll do that
this one is really lousy look at it okay
good good good
okay here we go i'm excited
oh no i don't know everyone's twitter
handles
oh okay you have to have someone here
what uh
halloween
right
okay who wants to be my friend everyone
right
oh no no oh no so i just want to give
everyone watching the context that um
we can all see each other's faces and
hear each other the whole time
yeah wait i didn't i'm gonna i'm gonna
ask the first question i don't know i
don't know this map i don't know this
map
yes
studio reacted and adapted to the game's
success
uh well sorry i'm like trying to do a
task while i talk
that's great um
yeah no it's honestly i mean they didn't
the game has been out for since 2018
right and the success was really sudden
um
so i think it's one of those things
where honestly as
someone's dead two people are dead
i just got a dead body okay
oh my goodness too so are you already
oh my god i'm in the very beginning um i
i just went to oh yeah i'm sorry yes
it's
me hello i'm kat i i called body after i
left the
med bay and was going up in the hallway
and i saw
david i don't know where med bay even is
med bay was like
so right when we leave that intro place
it's like the first room to your right
i went like straight up i went through
the like vented hallway and i was upset
alone
i was about to come up there so i was
yeah in the vended hallway and
because i have two tasks up there but i
have no idea where that's like there's
like a
i was sorting rocks or something did you
vent into the hallways
was in with me and i was trying to
answer the question
i feel like i saw i think cat
get um did you get body scanned
i did yes so i feel like i sold out
twice
yeah which i think yeah we did see cat
get body scanned
well i didn't i mean i at the very least
i saw kat stan
on the scanner i didn't actually yeah i
started when i was
going to the plant place
was it plants yeah it was like leaf
blowing
wow this is a bunch of pros love you
full of pros i don't know
i didn't see anything i can't really be
very much help right now skip this time
if we're feeling if we're not feeling
like pretty certain wow interesting
felix really wants to wait
yeah no i'm just kidding
felix
it's too early to know okay i can't
believe two people died already that's
really scary oh
i know right
no it's not it's not in this version of
the game no
um dead people that can actually speak
because i have to keep asking questions
even though you killed them
okay so you were saying
you were saying do you want me to repeat
the questions i asked uh youth please
okay it's basically how the studio has
reacted to the to the reception of the
game
and how they have to adopt it too yeah
so
i think one of the things that's
interesting about it is that
well one they've realized they need to
expend so they hired me on to be the
community director which means like they
had a lot of trouble i think just
keeping up with everyone and seeing what
everyone was saying about the game so
i sort of i'm taking on that role
they are taking on a bunch of
contractors to help them out and
honestly
i think one of the biggest things is
that they're they have been working on
this game
like since it's come out and improving
it and all that so i think they're
really just
sticking with that kind of ethos and
making sure that
the game is fun but also tackling the
fact that with more players you have a
little bit
more um let's say like a little
sometimes a little more toxic a little
bit
more uh moderation that needs to happen
in the game so that's kind of the
priority right now
uh in terms of making sure the game is
fun and welcoming for everyone
nice perfect i love that in a video game
i'm so bad at multitasking i just really
know i'm here
when you create a character um do you
illustrate it with an idea of how
exactly that character is going to
animate or are you surprised by the work
of the animators
uh well i tend to animate most of the
stuff that i actually draw
so i do find that um it's important for
me to think about sort of like
how things will animate while i'm
drawing them and all of that but uh
i think that oops emergency meeting i'll
finish that thought
did you see how good that was i died in
the middle of talking and i didn't even
let it i have no idea
while she's giving an answer like that's
it that was cool
what happened well i saw her
tiny little dead body because she has
two bodies she has the big body and the
tiny body
and i saw both bodies it wasn't so sad
so i went
and i pressed the red spot for sure it's
staffy
was hanging around me but i was talking
and i think she was being really polite
because i was still trying to answer a
question
so i saw her like hovering around my
body
how many imposters are there are there
two two
oh no wait i'm with felix i'm with felix
in this room with like this kind of
thingy
yeah i actually don't know what is simon
says puzzle which is the worst when
you're trying to focus
on someone and also do assignments do
not do that that was bad
um i don't know if i finished it or not
i got i got to the final one but then
emergency being was called but yeah
we're up we're up past the
in the reactor that's where we are in
the rear that's what it is i did see you
guys go in there when i left i did
i did yeah you were leaving and it was
me and marlo
say something in spanish
okay i don't know what you said but it
was sexy
okay okay okay i think it's stephanie
just got
no one i'm split no one was there no
one's
already voted wow okay um okay so marlo
you were saying finish the i'll finish
that thought yeah
i think that i need to go i usually play
double time i do illustration and
animation for the projects that i work
on so i do oftentimes have to think
about animation when i'm designing a
character and
for games especially you have to think
about things like will this character be
like
swinging a huge sword or an axe or
something and that means their arms have
to be long enough to go over their head
and like all of that kind of stuff so uh
yeah when when i'm working on character
design i absolutely am
uh trying to keep in mind sort of the
practicality of how things animate
as well as how they look good i knew it
oh my god
this is such a hard way to play this
game
i knew it man oh my gosh
the fact that you can't speak about
anything that you're doing or
facial expressions um is is just utter
chaos my gosh
i just wanna say i just want to say like
i was the first one to die
and i was kicked by my mother oh yes you
were the first one oh i actually
hit the exit i couldn't even get out of
the main room
i'm sorry you were just standing there
you know i have to go for it we asked
the question
okay okay
i need to not be i like
was so my i was so split focused i
almost like
didn't understand that it was steffy who
killed me even though i saw it happen
this i've never played this game this
way it's going to be a learning
experience for everyone very
oh okay so we have to give you the new
code i'll give it to you
right here card uh it should just be the
same thing
oh no it's the same code yeah it is let
me get back unless we have
a real imposter and then
i got this i got this there we go so
stephanie you can throw it right away
okay please god
her face everyone poke her face listen
this is why i have this so i can just
hide behind it
yeah um i don't know man
i'm so scared yeah that's
can't believe you would suspect me in
the first round okay cat
yes what what drew you to uh sound
designing games instead of like
film tv music industry like why games
sure
well i really like that with games it's
a very interactive media
so like with with movies and film well
movies and film film and tv and other
types of animation it's very linear so i
really like the idea that like in games
you know the way felix will play the way
victoria might play would be
vastly different and the way they might
experience audio can
kind of shift um even though there's an
overarching
goal of what the soundscape should be
like everyone's experience is slightly
different so i really like that unique
element of that
nice very cool i don't know how to deal
with the task oh my god how did i get it
there's a few that are scary i'm going
i'm going to put
alanna's multitasking
careers in the industry um but with a
very clear goal
on the long term that you have now
accomplished have you had your steps
drawn out
to accomplish this or you've kept
adapting yourself to the opportunities
that you've had in front of you
um my goals definitely uh
changed so you know i've always loved
writing and i've always loved video
games those have been my two passions in
life
um so first it was games media which
still worked because i was a writer
um virtually my whole career there so it
was the same thing
um and then that evolved into as someone
who was writing like books and stories
and stuff
up
wait what happened
um i found it in the
what like the corridor between like when
you're trying to get to
comedy it has a name victoria is it the
like
airline
[Laughter]
okay so alana and i were were hanging
out over
in the bottom left whatever that is
uh and alana did not murder me this time
or last time but did not murder me so
that's
my only that's the only piece i have is
that yeah i did not murder me i plant
plenty ample opportunity
i feel like i was walking towards there
but i saw like five people in the same
spot
that's like well i was trying to get to
the reactor because apparently yeah i
was on fire
we should probably
oh i have i have a med base scan if
anybody wants to come watch me do it
right after this
i'm on a platform i'm on a platform same
and i have no idea how to toggle it i've
been trying to press it for the password
i think you have to press space that's
convenient you have to like press
so there's no space there's no space
yeah i've had that's what i'm saying
all right i've had that problem before
this is the hottest and easiest way to
play this game i feel like we should
maybe only have one imposter
because i think the imposters are good
because we're all so distracted
i agree with this is them
you were saying i was saying yeah i've
written books and stories and stuff my
whole life and then when i was like i
think i want to get into writing video
games i basically
um have been doing that quietly working
on that for the last five years
technically
um so that was really
the goal um and i think that one of the
the biggest of many of course privileges
that i am afforded
is that um i've always been a person who
just knows exactly what i want to do
which i know a lot of people don't quite
have a clear-cut path that way it's
it's very helpful that i'm like well
here's what i want to do next and here's
what i want to do next so i just look at
the things that i think are needed for
me to be able to do that thing and then
work towards that
um so yeah i definitely uh feel like
my whole career has been leading to the
position that i am in now which is
um video game writer at santa monica
studio and it was certainly
uh again thanks to me just kind of
knowing what i want
something that that was um uh
i i definitely knew the steps that i had
to take also from talking to other
people in the industry and all that and
had a lot of support
um but i feel like is also a testament
to
how wonderful the industry is when it
comes to like i i was able to sit in in
a few writers rooms to learn how
um some studios write video games and i
was able to write on some projects
uh you know that didn't require me to
have
shipped a triple a video game so there
are a lot of different avenues to get
into
um i guess game dev and uh my path is
is one of them and it's been a very
exciting journey and i i hope to write
many video games over the next however
many years
i think i did yeah you did you played
them all
so eloquent
um billy i'm gonna i'm gonna take
advantage of your
death to ask you a question
all my tossing
felix and i knew they were okay because
i saw them scan
and they saw me scan but they can't say
that because they're very
convenient um it was in the cafeteria i
didn't
see anyone really walking from it but i
saw victoria
around it i don't know that's good
enough for me
we gotta start throwing him somewhere
yeah
i mean that's like the only thing i have
to go off of but i don't know
i you know i just i just voted for
victoria so we can get through with it
exactly i feel like you know
you're wrong but you gotta start making
some moves i will say david had
opportunity to kill me and didn't but
also david is also distracted
so i don't know that that clears
anything
very good at the poker face i always i'm
not good at poker face at
all i'm with someone in the
decontamination
hallway who dat
they didn't kill me so that's great it's
the saints
i see who who are they voting for
felix i'm so sorry i voted for victoria
just because
that's the only name i heard yeah same
i'm just willing to go full case
really you can vote me off i guess i've
done my tasks
who hasn't
i guess like we know felix was having
some trouble maybe that could hold us up
i guess on the cremate side
okay billy yes you've worked in
character design for both real
world characters and fictional almost
cartoon-like characters
uh which one do you post or which
presents a bigger challenge
oh that's fantastic um i i think
i mean really not to sound super lame
it's like
both have unique challenges uh the
the you know real characters
um the the challenge is
bringing actually character through in a
way that's not
completely tied to the the realistic
um you know betrayal like the actual
like
this person looks like someone else or
at least a little bit like that person
um
and and making sure that the performance
and the nuances of the performance come
through
um whereas the challenge with the
stylized characters
um really comes into like the movement
and
facial expressions and like everything
is that it's
uh like over-the-top and stylized
feeling unique and and and like that
coming through
just as true
i'm really bad at multitasking
yeah are you having trouble murdering
people
i'm having trouble answering questions
and and moving around
and uh like everything
got to get those ghost tops i'm getting
i'm getting some from the chat
um you where's david
i'm adding something with a purple
diamond thingy i don't see you
i see you if someone's gotta be dead
someone has to be dead
somewhere we have been playing this one
for a while
okay so i have one for cat yes um
oh gosh okay they want to know what
games have you worked in
and how did you get a chance to start
working in audio for video games
okay that's from joe tapia from the chat
tapia i don't wanna die so i'm gonna run
around
so
[Laughter]
where are my friends um so actually
when i went to college um i was very
much supposed to be
your stand-up typical asian
is the best way i can wear that i
understand
yes so um originally i was going to
school
specifically to do pre-med oh no the
lights are cards
it's cool i got it don't worry about it
don't worry about it i'm just gonna i'm
gonna hang out right in here
guys don't don't worry about me um
and that was my that was my journey i
was supposed to be
a doctor didn't really have any thoughts
outside of that because
um uh for a little background i am a
first-gen american
and i'm the oldest so it's very much
like this is your this is your given
task i'm like got it
done um but then in college i realized
like this is not what i want to do
so i switched my majors and i was going
to psychology and child learning and
development because i wanted to do
research instead
and then i met my husband in college and
he's like yo
you want to make some music for my game
and i'm like [ __ ] what
it's like okay yes i play piano like
most asian people do um
but playing music is so different than
like composing music because when you do
that
you're trying to pull all these random
thoughts and merge them into something
that makes sense
um so i did it and i was like oh no i
love this
and then ended up making some sounds for
his games as well
and ended up really loving that and then
um
after college i'm like okay i can either
go and try and get my doctorate
for psychology or i can try and get to
the game industry
and i went that route instead and my
first gig was a
as an intern for gearbox so i worked on
borderlands 1.
and then i was super green and i'm like
all right i'm done here i don't want to
work on
shooters for the rest of my life and
then i left and moved to austin and
kind of explored in that route too
i can't remember what the other question
was but i like
that that was the question that was a
question yeah thank you i like that i
didn't die so that's cool
i have one from for alana from lemoski
she's one of the he's one of the biggest
content creators in panama so oh cool
um yeah yeah yeah someday you'll meet
him at an event will
go or something he's really great he
says
if i don't remember okay wait wait let
me just translate in my head first
um
okay no no that's fine that's fine um
you
have spoken in the past of how
single-player games
um were threatened by like twitch by
streaming
um what's your poster on that now so
and especially knowing that you're now
working on on
i should say that was not my opinion um
that was just
i interviewed i think it was 26 total
developers
um so definitely never never an opinion
i personally was expressing i was just
uh you know doing journalism
ooh somebody's dead um reporting the
information
oh wow okay i just want to say that is
absolutely not alana because we've just
been like
following each other around the whole
time yeah
uh it's not it's not it's not alana and
it's not marlow
i think it's this definitely yeah
i think that it is too because you are
dead
i think that oh i can't talk yeah and i
don't know anything
i think that it is i didn't even see
when they killed me
like they were exactly look
every single time she would stop moving
and then something would get sabotaged
so i think that i'm very suspicious of
it
okay so it's up to me and you molo in
that
like if we're wrong yeah the game is
thrown so we have to pick correctly here
um i really think it's i really think
it's it's steffi
i do i think so too because like i was
loafing in that room and marla and elana
were there i'm like okay
you guys could have killed me
but why is it not you though cat oh
because i can't multitask
right you could have been standing there
while you know in between
well and that's why so few people have
died around
i could have but i don't want to kill
both you and and marlo right after i
finished
and then that would have been a quick i
have no idea
steffy has such a good jawbone that i
would be suspicious of that
hey
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna vote for steffy
and i hope that it's right
it's just my gut feeling well i don't
have a say now
because it's that's the majority so i
guess we'll see
i'm not sure who did you vote for steffy
no stephanie voted for me
what i really have a right i think i
don't know yeah
it's got to be stuffy it has to be thank
god
i knew it was youtube oh my god
you were so scary stuffy you were so
scared
i was like popping in
is that you were with us for so long but
to be fair we were like chasing you
around together yeah
i think i think i oh i think i called a
hillbilly and it was just like
i killed him and then everyone came down
and i screamed
this time right and there's ghosts
i kept like we were talking because
stephie killed me and victoria killed
you
and so we were chatting so um but but i
kept just typing like every single
i was following stuffy around just see
who you kill
and you were you were very good at like
not
like just letting people exist near you
i love dangerous quality you came for me
last time
and i was like i'm gonna carry on i came
for you but i was right
and i killed you that is true
i just want to remind everyone that when
this ends
i still have to live with her oh spooky
i've watched a lot of forensic files so
if you're
taking out a life insurance on youtube
oh my gosh i know
it's always the life insurance policy
don't tell her that
you know my cat tells me i'm scary
and now i have to believe it because i
just met you
guys i don't think you're scared i am
scared okay
okay
[Laughter]
another one with two imposters we did
well the last oh okay because
wait no oh yes i i would start go ahead
go ahead
i like to because then you have a buddy
yes
[Laughter]
and then like we lo i lost immediately
because you're like cat you suck come
back
now people are gonna get revenge i'm
scared now
well don't be a bad guy
just don't murder murder it's that easy
it's just fun okay i'm sorry elena we
interrupted your answer
yes okay so the question was about um
uh dev saying that that um twitch was
hurting single-player games
um yeah so i interviewed i think it was
26 different
um developers about that from a lot of
different perspectives
uh ultimately the thesis is that you
know your massive
aaa games are not going to be hurt by
this um it can hurt games and
and did provably hurt a game called that
dragon cancer
um which was uh this really really
lovely indie game where a lot of people
were doing let's plays and streams that
meant that people were less inclined
to actually play the game themselves and
the studio noticed a
decline and damn it
two people oh [ __ ] oh
sorry oh wait i can swear i can attest
it was not alana
i watched alana get body skin like the
body scanner
i was going to say i just did the
reactor with alana
yeah but it was right outside the
reactor how convenient
it was right outside the reactor and the
only other person i saw was david who
was sorting
rocks or something right now i didn't
even see anyone walk into there
so where did you find the body outside
the body was like right outside of the
reactor but it was uh
like where the hallway opens up and kind
of right outside the reactor
they missed it does that mean that
somebody killed someone while we were
doing reactive i
think so and the only other person i saw
was david unless you can vent from there
or something i don't know
i think there is eventually yeah i was
doing rocks that's all i was saying
let me see your faces first time i do
rocks i had no idea you had like
bones uh you voted early why did you
vote so early
yeah you're very sure of yourself are
you the imposter billy i'm gonna i'm
gonna skip billy
your life wasn't there i don't know
so who did you vote for
uh who did i vote for yeah
yes
and why ellen i'm not telling you
i voted for billy so i don't know i'm
like i'm pretty suspicious of the
strategy
just because they were the only other
person who was in that sort of area
there so that is also fair unless it was
you and i completely missed it molly
that's that's my concern
like we were right there i don't know
it was like nine seconds
stays i'm gonna i'm gonna vote for billy
just because
wow thanks wow i mean you didn't say you
know it was pretty weird i don't know
it kind of it was a strange strat billy
i don't know what you want us to do
i have no idea this is just wait
all right uh to continue answering the
question
okay we won't know if yeah okay you were
saying
um so hard 26. yeah so this is unlikely
to actually have any influence on
major aaa games it provably has not i
mean you know spider-man ps4 sold
incredibly well
um horizon zero dawn uh ghost of
tsushima uh
god of war all all successfully selling
games um but
it can hurt very specific um
story-driven experiences and again this
is coming from the perspective of devs
but the thing that i think
is a little bit more concerning on a
larger scale is that a lot of games are
being made
to tailor to uh um twitch streamers
uh to to tailor to that audience where
basically you get recurring content out
of the fact that different people are
playing
uh it's the players making the content
not the developers so a game like pub g
the content comes from the different
people doing different things every time
more so than it does from oh no oh no oh
no um
the the game itself okay we got out of
that one
oh my god way out of the question it's
no the reactive meltdown
is david why would they mean is it i was
scanning myself
did anybody saw me scanning myself just
so we don't die
and i was near the scanner when you were
scanning yourself
i was getting kidding i don't know if
it's david you were not near me i was
scanning myself and the thing is
if you vote me out it's like it's only
four of us we'll we'll definitely
but there can only mathematically be one
impossible or the other one we will
write about
one i mean if we were right about one of
them yes because we don't know
i'm still very suspicious wouldn't we
have lost the game i'm not sure
if there is no the game the game doesn't
tell us if the imposter is out
no i just yeah i lost if they were if it
was 2v2
i'm not sure um no they voted they they
oh i don't know i don't know who did you
vote for muller
i voted for david because david was next
to us when they
could be marlo i know it's i don't i
actually don't think it's you this time
stuffy
i'm gonna go david i don't know if i
i don't think it's steffy i except he
seems too earnest this time
yeah but she's always really pretty it's
cheating i trust anything she says
that's not fair thank you and what
no way i really hope this was right malo
you've just pulled off something
truly evil if i'm wrong
you're gonna shatter me i wish that
now we don't know oh no we don't know
we don't know what if it's alana
i've been clear i've been cleared i know
so you're scanning i saw you scanning i
said you scanned
okay okay okay okay i'm gonna follow you
i don't wanna die
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna uh ask a
question that's for all of you guys
oh wait i'll do that afterwards
wait what i just we're gonna get
murdered
and lose or we vote someone out steffy
i'm pretty sure i trust you we're voting
out marlo
yes it's marlo yes no i'm not fine
but i'm pretty sure yes all i know is
that
alana and i did the reactor together
sorry correct
don't think it's alana well and
stephanie saw you
tan no i saw you i don't know
yeah i'm just gonna i don't know i'll
vote for steffi cause
we have to
you know ghosts are not doing their work
where that's concerned um
you have i'm now thinking we were wrong
about david is what i think has happened
which means i'm going mom
i think marlow was the murderer there i
think david was incorrect and i got
played
i don't know how you like i don't know
how i would have been there you did it
and i didn't see it
and then you walked out you were like oh
no alana's going to see this so you went
and did it while i was doing my task
that was really good molly
wow
i killed the first person like right in
front of david and i don't know how you
didn't see that
like i don't know what happened i am so
distracted
i i i have no defense i have no i really
i really like ma
i like marlow's strategy of just
completely throwing me
under the bus immediately well no
you threw yourself under the bus why are
you the other impossibility
she was even like that's what threw me
off and she was like completely
like just throwing me under the bus no
no like
it was not this chat was like me look at
marlo
like she's just so good at this i
wouldn't believe
okay a quick fire quick fire question
for all of you guys uh
lord from our chat asks
which would you say is your favorite
game and why
deadly premonition oh it's the best
video okay let's let's
okay that's the premonition alanna felix
uh of all time yeah like your favorite
game your favorite
yeah that's really really hard for me
but i'm gonna go with the one that is
like currently
in my head because it is uh it has
you know when you play a game and you're
like no this is the one and then about
like
eight months later you're like okay okay
my favorite game is the one that i like
because earthbound is always my my
original it's like
it's all right but having played persona
5 royal again
it might be one of the best games ever
it is it is like
it's up there in one of the best games
ever made so
uh right now that's my answer but i
think earthbound is like my true
the true in the core of me billy
okay of all time yeah yeah like your
favorite thing
any platform yeah it has to be
a house uh on the arcade
yeah okay yeah yeah all right
choice yeah big
grip is my spirit animal
this is so hard can everyone else go
first
um capsule force
oh that's a good solid answer good thank
you thank you
marlon my favorite game of all time is
chrono trigger for the super nintendo
nice yeah yeah i play that like yearly
and vic i still haven't played
oh i think for now i have to say
undertale because when that game came
out it came at the perfect time that i
needed it
for sure
there's someone that's not inside this
one
oh i didn't know who do we wanna
start i love undertale so much yeah yeah
let's start over
here let's start over i think it's billy
billy's wait wait
let me let me um i'm gonna leave you
with one more question and i'll help
steffi
um setting up the next round yeah i'm
gonna use the restroom really quick
i'll be right back i have two like
really dirty glasses like this game
makes me sweat
a little not good
is a great question from the chat it
comes from cristiano rodriguez
he's asking who do you guys think
is going to win um the game award for
the best game of the year
what are the nominees oh hold on standby
i know
the last of us part two
don't say of course i think the last of
us will probably win but i think i would
go hades
yeah i would i would want hades to win
personally
i've been playing the crap out of hades
man i love that game
it's really good oh my gosh so good
popular thought i don't like award
ceremony stuff
because there's so many games that are
not it's true
in the limelight then it's like
yeah it's true yeah i think what i'm
gonna do really well is like
like a lot of people who and it's easy
to forget this when you work in the
industry a lot of people who are
watching that show like
will never have heard of hades so the
fact that it's in that lineup is really
like that's very cool like obviously
untitled goose game the amount of awards
that that game won when it wasn't
necessarily like
that well known similar for disco
elysium
there are definitely things like award
shows can bring exposure to smaller
titles for sure it's nice seeing
that just in general like the industry
like really raising up
indie games and smaller titles that you
normally don't hear about you're right
it's not their benefits i think that's
actually the thing the thing that i like
about
uh you know uh twitch streaming and
uh game awards especially right now like
we're
going all the way back to the top where
we were talking about um
the impact that uh covet and work from
home and everything has had
on games i think there's a lot of these
games that wouldn't have even had a
chance
if it hadn't been for the situation that
we're in right now
yeah this is yet another reciprocal
part of that um i mean
that's fine yeah yeah there are benefits
i do i do
sort of think that like sometimes they
they can feel a little bit
um reductive and and the the juries of
generally very like-minded people i i've
been on the game awards jury the last
four years i'm not this year
um but you know i i definitely like
seeing like the amount of love that
disco eliseum got
for being nominated for writing when a
lot of people had never
[Applause]
among us
that's why i use touch that's why i use
the ipad because i would not there's so
many of them and i'm like i don't know
what i'm supposed to do
okay uh vic i have a question for you
hello i was reading one of your blogs
um where you speak about summing up your
role as a character development
for communities what do you mean by that
and can you
expand on that idea because i think it's
amazing
sorry as a uh what for communities yeah
you said that
you sum up your role as character
development
for communities right yes so what did
you meant by that and because i think
it's a great concept i just want you to
go into it thank you
yeah so what i mean by that is i think
that
um no matter what game like i think a
lot of people think that if it's like a
violent game like there's no way you
could have like a very healthy community
that
wants to help each other out or you know
like get along and all that
um but what a community manager
or in my case a community director
should
do and i think like is there a task is
like to show
everyone how like how they can interact
with each other
somebody's dead
that's amazing oh
wow wow
can't we make a rule that if someone is
answering a question
no i think it adds to it i think it
makes it better
that's so funny
you know that they're prey at that point
though oh my gosh
that was okay okay i found i found
victoria
i was in the greenhouse growing plants
which is the thing apparently you can do
with the touch
down i came down and i went sort of uh
that's it's a v
from there right it kind of yeah so i
went down
on the left and and found half of
victoria
as it were
which we all knew happened okay i can
clear that
hillbilly your boy hillbilly did not do
this because
yeah he and i were in reactor and i
think marlo i was gonna say
i saw hillbilly coming out of reactor
which is like so far away from there so
i would assume that it wasn't him i was
going up there
is the reactor the thing when you press
a button
it's like like a long hole with like
light yeah
okay i was there too okay you were in
reactor
oh my gosh
oh my gosh look um
it's not me why are you voting so early
every time
yeah i'm gonna skip i'm gonna skip i
have no clue
i don't know i i have i owe it yeah i
always saw the body and i literally
didn't see anybody like in that i'm
assuming they came up and went down
because there was no one in the
greenhouse oh
there was someone in the greenhouse with
me was it victoria
yeah well i actually don't know i
actually don't like
are you recording the body that you
killed
i'm gonna follow you oh a self-report uh
i mean i could be i'm not but you know
can you sell food
i didn't know that yeah yeah i didn't
know that until it took me like five
games to realize you can self-report
wait um killed billy hillbilly voted
immediately and voted for someone oh
we did that last time and he was the
impossibility because
he was all against you is he just mean
i keep going just very judgmental in my
body
no this is not money that can get up
there this is not the way okay
sorry vic you were you were saying yes
i'm sorry
she wasn't dying this is like a
challenge for you guys
i know this is this is our heart mode
among us
while being murdered it's time but yeah
no i
i i basically would some like the reason
i say like
you design the communities that you want
it's that you want
you basically have this sort of um
influence and power over ooh another
dead one
oh man okay we're gonna wait uh so i
found cat
okay um
[Music]
right in front of like one of the wisest
thing that's in one of the the whole way
to the left like next to rihacta
um i don't know
i was i went up the hallway and i was
sorting rocks next to the reactor and i
didn't see anybody the whole time
the the buddy
because yeah wait where was that my body
it's me because i reported the debt okay
do you i have a very important question
that it will take up time i'm sorry uh
alana do you have egg on your face i
like that i like that a lot i'm just
gonna start using that in the future
yeah
that's good i like that
interesting interesting time wasting
sorry i'm sorry
as soon as i thought i was like i need
to ask about this but i didn't want to
interrupt the question while you were
talking
so i apologize i don't know i don't know
who it is but
steffi is quieter than usual that is
true
the first time she hasn't spoken like in
what four games
well david remember that whole thing
about how you still have to live with
her
i have my my daughter's not sitting here
so i have a spare room i'm good
i can still kill you from the spare room
no i haven't already
i don't think i've seen marlo once this
entire game yeah i haven't seen felix
like at all either
i haven't seen you once so i'm only i'm
assuming
okay well i don't actually know anything
about minting to be honest so but i i
don't know if you can see people when
i'm trying to see if i can see
your ipad reflection in your in your
glasses
i don't know who it is i don't know who
it is i don't know it's killing me
but i want to think it's felix because i
felix is exactly this very suspicious
i've voted for feelings
i voted
honestly i don't even know if i can like
continue i don't remember what i
said at this rate um but yeah basically
you can
you create the communities that you want
to
do you get to influence uh
them based on i guess the way you uh set
the rules the way you interact in them
um and yeah i think we can just you can
create better communities and
help people understand like how to talk
online with each other
yeah i think that applies like for any
type of community you know what i mean
especially nowadays
yeah and it's so important because like
you want to have a space in your games
or in your communities that
people feel safe and comfortable talking
in and are held accountable for their
actions
yep definitely how do you balance making
that feel
genuine without it being too like force
fed that like be nice to each other
yeah i mean the thing about it is that
you never have to like overtly
i don't think like many of us have been
in like actual like situations where
someone has yelled like just be nice to
each other whatever
um but what you can do is be
kind of the role model for the kind of
vibe and the
sort of community that you want so like
when you are managing people when you
are
creating these communities it's like you
get to be the person that they can look
up to and like whatever jokes you make
that they're going automatically going
to see that as being the most acceptable
thing to do so
if you are the one making i don't know
like really
spicy jokes and they're like oh okay
like that means i can say it too so it's
kind of just
um interacting with them in a way that
you want them to reflect
dig it
oh this one was crazy i think this is
hard
vic that was a that was a great answer
to a hard question while you're playing
a game which i
yeah yeah yeah you know i'm like i hoped
i was like i hope this makes sense
because i'm
trying to do tasks and i'm like
confirmed it's a party
how does a service like physics are you
listening to
damn yeah okay how does a service like
game pass or any other paid subscription
that comes
our way will benefit indie game
development
i mean listen there's lots of different
reasons to
um for devs to make games and one of
them is sustainability and the ability
to like eat
a meal and pay rent and steffy's face is
very shocked you see you yeah but look
at that jawbone
[Laughter]
thank you you know like we all we all
wanna we all wanna make
uh the dream project of our lives and
and make sure that we know where
we are uh oh dear oh
oh dear sorry uh
and things like game pass offer us a
clear way to
potentially make some of that some of
that runway back even before the game is
out
um you know places like microsoft have
been doing an incredible job of
partnering with indies in ways that are
really really
uh beneficial to the indies and and also
mean that we're able to continue making
games without us without worrying about
what the game sells really well or not
and that's awesome
so there are really big upsides also i
like i would argue
while it is really important that you
make a buck on your game um
right about felix
the reason i was so shocked was i was
trying to answer david earnestly and he
just
murders me
okay okay one thing one thing one thing
i i just killed someone like i was not
looking at the name
and then i saw it was you and i felt so
bad and i felt good
then david and i were just running
around together for a little bit yeah
i was like oh we're [ __ ] invincible
now and then you rejected me which was
fair that was fair
and i thought i thought marlowe knew
because you were following me
downstairs and i thought you were going
to that to press the button
because you saw me killing alanna and
then when you stood behind me and i'm
like okay i just have to wait for 10
seconds i followed both of you because i
was like
but i wasn't sure enough so i was
following you for a second
and then i completely i fixed it
the entirety of i think oxygen oxygen
yeah
and i fixed both of them and i was like
what are you all doing
[Music]
i was just telling people that we're
like 60 bucks away from the goal
while it is really important that um you
know you were able to sort of
pay a rent and eat a meal as an indie
creator especially
um i think one of the most tragic things
about releasing a game is
is not if you didn't make any money but
if no one played it and what's so cool
about subscription services right now
especially
i think i'm going to speak to game pass
because it came up in the question but
like
um i'm sure other ones work like this as
well uh it's so cool
that people who never might like would
have never tried your game
have the freedom to try your game and
the data is showing that it is not
actually that it is cannibalizing or or
reducing sales in any way but rather
introducing your game your genre to
someone who maybe
never would touch it and so that is
super dope like when you get to see
how many people have touched your game
especially ones that maybe
don't typically play games like yours as
an indie it's
it's like it's pretty cool because you
get to think like okay maybe this person
discovered something
through my game or through my art uh
that maybe they probably wouldn't have
themselves and paid
you know with their pay while there and
so i think there's some really
incredible
uh long-term hopefully long-term
uh genre expanding like side effects of
something like the subscription service
of course there's also the worry that
like you know people get used to only
buying only playing the games that are
free to them etc etc
and that comes with a little bit of like
you know accessibility etc and an
opportunity that
is oh am i what am i oh we lost
oh my god
i know um i i was just gonna add to that
felix uh
uh one of rose city's games is on the
epic store right now for free download
and it is actually
so cool to see how many people who like
hadn't heard about the game before are
playing it it's like absolutely bonkers
it's so much fun
yeah uh corey just messaged me with how
cool it is as well as we were playing
which did distract me while i was
imposter so corey is
thanks corey part of the reason i was so
cool is marlo's co-worker and
the the reason i was so suspicious in
the last round for sure yeah
um really neat to see it is really neat
to see and and you know i i joke about
money being the main motivator to make
games but people playing it and and
reach
and yeah just the idea that because it
sucks to make something and then know
that no one had eyes on it like that's
just so tragic
it really is a hard thing to stomach
and it happens like a lot a lot i mean
the majority come on oh who's sabotage
lana's gonna come back and be dead just
because
all right well i'm leaving
yes okay uh billy one question for you
yeah we can restart we can restart we
can restart
i'm sorry i
don't say it out loud kramer
hey billy a question for you um when
directing a cinematic for a video game
what are you taking
into consideration that differs from
live-action cinematography
uh level design for the for the
mission itself uh uh and and it's it's
something that's kind of like it's a
really
i'll say fun and challenging back and
forth
uh because you know there's definitely
been times i know where we've
set something out we've shot we've gone
down to la
with the actors on the stage we've shot
everything we've started working through
it
things start coming together and guess
what the mission isn't testing very well
they have to change the layout
you we have to make some different you
know different decisions
and then we kind of have to macgyver
backwards and figure out uh how to do it
because you know
i mean i don't know other studios may
just go and say hey let's reshoot and
for us it's not as much of a
consideration so
we have to kind of do some creative
problem solving
that's pretty cool that's so cool that's
interesting it's also it's also neat to
hear that you take that into account
because i think it might be easy for
some places to say these two things are
completely separate and not take into
account the fact that they're deeply
linked
right and so yeah that's really cool and
you and you can you can definitely tell
that by playing the game
like the game is constantly being at the
ground
yeah and um yeah i mean it's announcing
and it's one of the things that i think
is the benefit of like for us even
our you know our trailers we make
in-house but
just even our cinematics department
being in-house and being so engaged and
and we do a lot of you know animators on
cinematics we do
gameplay animation and vice versa and
you know everybody
collaborates across a bunch of different
uh disciplines
at the studio because we're kind of like
a little big studio um
and so so it's it's it's it's great that
everybody kind of has like this
awareness
and then also we all understand that the
game wins at the end of the day
um yeah and if things have to change
they have to change
i have a question here from raul munoz
who says
for those of us who are standing
starting to learn how to
develop a game we we actually now have
um
that career being taught here in panama
um
what would you say what what i don't
know how to translate this
it is
yeah like how how what were any of you
guys advice would be of
what to study and like what that career
path should be to start
and and get uh get a kind of get a
fitting inside of the industry
i have a quick answer yeah do it
you have so many things that you can
pull outside
of a given education route that
can benefit your games um there's like
for example if we're just thinking about
sound design
what i've learned in psychology is
extremely important what i've learned
in history classes it's extremely
important art
anything that i absorb from watching
film or listening to things on the radio
i think what people forget is that games
are so much more than your education
routes i've seen students come from
specific game
universities and you know sometimes
people assume that
because i have received this education
i'm going to get a job
and i'm an immediate shoe-in and that's
not the case a lot of times
um if you're only constrained to what
you've learned within that box
you're limiting yourself to what kind of
creativity you can really explore
so for me the big thing that i tell
students is to find other
students and work on your own games
together
find game jams and be part of that
because there's so much you can learn
from being
in small groups and organizations and
making games
and it's even in a very small time frame
um that you might not necessarily learn
in school i think we all have a question
too but
i also vote first let's vote for
ourselves
the body was in that like the room like
with the computer in it when you just
sort of go through the first hallway i
don't know what it's called
to the right i don't know what it is
yeah he just doesn't get lost
getting taken out right from the jump
every round i don't know
i don't know uh i don't think that it's
victoria because i think
tori and i both had the diagnostics test
uh
task forever um because we're both
standing there for a long time
i saw you and i just said
i'll go later
i i know alana is not or at least didn't
kill
billy because we were at the like the
plants
thing where the rocks are and stuff i
think i can confirm it
because i actually saw a lana being body
scanned so like i think that's like
the number that's like the one visual
one where you're like for sure it's not
yeah so like okay i can't multitask
not much down here i'm just gonna skip
i'm going to i think it's david
yeah i skipped i skipped vote david too
i think it's david
david are we voting david is that
besides
what's the case it's like literally a
matter of like
elimination for me yeah i don't think
it's alana i know it's not me i don't
think it's victoria
you were the only one that voted for me
yeah
yeah yeah here's what happened here's
what happened
i think it was i'm actually i'm actually
not interested in any of your reasons
too
[Laughter]
cafeteria oh my god why isn't the
cafeteria
link to the med day this isn't cheap i
know this map is is a real mess
it's so big i have some opinions for the
creators of this game
hey marlon yes uh
um how does someone start
illustrating and doing concept art for
video games like what's the route for
that
i think my answer kind of echoes at the
end of what kat was talking about where
i think for me
my path was really uh involved in
finding a local community
so i started going to uh portland indie
game squad events um which happened here
whoa what i just straight-up saw
steph kill someone okay
dip my toes into making games and
participating in game jams i think
if you can find a group of people that
you can kind of like have a low stakes
game making sort of
uh situation with that's so helpful um
i started getting work based on stuff
that i did in game jams and work that i
shared from working on game jams and it
kind of snowballs into
getting professional work as a
freelancer and all that kind of stuff so
i think that's the first step
and luckily uh i know that portland
indie game squad we're doing everything
online right now just because of kovid
so there's a lot of communities online
that you can
um participate in and do jams with
remotely uh which is sort of what we're
experiencing a lot of the time and i
think that uh that's a really good way
to get started and at least get to know
people
make a couple games not have really high
stakes for it and then start getting
your foot in the door
i think especially i have students like
it's super important to do that
when you know when you don't necessarily
have a whole bunch of
financial burdens ideally um
and i i wish that was something that i
had done more of when i was in school
back then yeah yeah i have a question i
have a question for like our group
has everybody did who did everybody come
complete university here
uh i did yeah yeah so i did not
i did not complete university and uh
but i did learn a lot in university that
i use and none of it was game related
and this is like a combination of both
the answers that happened in the
past two answers it for me is that like
uh
very i know very few people who can say
their degree 100
uh equip them for games but i know
almost everybody who went to school even
for in a short amount of time even
and like at all in life like any job
you've ever had
did teach them something about working
with the team which is
90 of game dev 100 working with a team
and realizing how you work with the team
and who cat just reported somebody down
this is gonna be spicy
i don't know if this was already
reported but i just saw
my fellow egg egg buddy alana on the
floor oh
no i went i'm in one of those like v
hallways the one that goes to the left
to the cafeteria and stuff
um if you go i don't know
i know greenhouse is up here green house
is at the top then there's that hallway
that goes down and then it goes to the v
yeah
on the left fork
i don't even remember who were
suspicious of anyone victoria if you're
talking i can't hear you
at least i don't know if anybody else
can hear you can can you hear me now
yes yeah yeah okay that would explain it
so we're only missing one more imposter
so we have to vote for someone
um i'm i'm suspicious of both of you i
think it's david because he gets the
excuse
also because he murdered me in cold
blood last time he gets an excuse
of the question asking so not having to
say anything
and i'm inclined to trust cat because i
saw cat not doing anything when she was
answering a question
but i did the same thing because i can't
i'm gonna i'm gonna vote because first
she's silenced
i'm not who knows what you were saying
because like who kills people when they
answer questions like that's
bad but that talks about money for david
what about what i'm doing in this
round i mean if victoria voted for you
then at least
we're at least voting for one person for
sure
good luck y'all i hope that's right
i'm crying i will never trust cat again
here's the thing i accused david in
round one
and none of that none of y'all believe
me but i was
alright i was surprised so that's the
lesson here
tired of being less than a feeling
i just want to say that i just felt bad
about killing alanna
it should you because chi was having
such a fun time like running around
all the tasks were done so killing me is
fine i don't have anything left to do
it's all right how good did it feel to
kill me the person that almost ejected
you
i'm good i'm good felix let's just go
ahead to the next round
made you feel good though to kill me
right made you feel really good kill me
after i accuse you yeah
that's nice i felt
a lot of people told me if i didn't
finish it would be a really big problem
for me
yeah i know i would like to i would like
to think that i'm i'm very successful
and so while it doesn't necessarily open
up doors i'm not going to say it opens
doors for you to not finish
please stay in school if you're in
school if you're enjoying it and it
works for you
but the point is that like i know a lot
of people who can say their degree
didn't equip them 100 for games
but what they did learn in games did
equip them in some way and what i was
saying is that it's
about group projects or about group
management or about
anything that teaches you how you work
in a team so you can self-reflect on how
you're integrating into a team and what
that looks like and feels like for you
the better you can do that even if
you're not in management the better
you'll be
able to manage up because it's a big
part of of working in a team is
both managing up and managing laterally
right so like learning what your team is
like and then learning what your boss is
like and how you can
how you can sort of combine all that
when that applies to indy it applies to
triple
a i think i don't know i'm not in aaa
but i would think it does
and it applies to solo dev as well so
even if you plan on making games by
yourself
learning what that entails for you is
super important i think there's lots of
ways to get there
lots of ways to get there it's the same
thing for like even jobs that are
non-game related there's so many
soft skills that you are learning that
apply
so relevantly to to being in the game
industry and i think that's what a lot
of
um people don't really emphasize like
the soft skills that you're learning no
man
can help you succeed retail taught me a
lot about
hell yeah yeah yeah yeah
so much of it it's just like taking the
like taking
like sucking as much as you can like of
the positive as you can
from every like role you're in
crunch feels like because like retail
crunches all the time
in the world and knowing how you react
and like how and to feel that feeling
coming on so you can avoid it
and maybe develop a nurturing
environment where it's
not always happening in your life is
like yes to me retail was a hard lesson
learned
but it did equip me in in a way that
school just couldn't so i was gonna say
that for me
i went to art school so my degree is
kind of like a one-to-one for what i
ended up doing in
in games but i would say that the thing
that actually quit me the most for games
was learning how to do critique
and how to do critique positively and
take that's cool
um i think that giving constructive
criticism and receiving it is like the
most important skill in working in games
because you're working on a team but
you're also working on something that's
creative
so everyone has creative stakes in it
and you have to like understand that
like everyone has an ego and at the same
time you need to manage your own ego
oh who left them first that was wild
milo like completely piggybacking off of
yours i think especially like
you know as an artist and like for sound
designers and
a lot of creatives in the industry we're
always vulnerable
yeah totally like our work is so
subjective like at least with code it's
like all right it works
it doesn't work with with any kind of
creative aspect like you're always
vulnerable whether it be to your
co-workers or your direct people within
your discipline
or the general public and that is such a
rough thing
that i wish like i had learned that it's
okay to fail it's okay to fail you
should fail often you should receive
feedback and it's not always like
you know it's not a dig against you if
if someone doesn't like your work it's
sometimes it's just not the right fit
for that level or what a client's
looking for
yeah i think that kind of stuff was
super hard
yeah that was one of one of the talks i
uh gave at
gdc i think it was like 2016 was you
know the art of not giving a [ __ ]
like uh
and it is it's it's an art it's hard for
it's hard for people
to um to feel comfortable
not being comfortable yeah
more important and i think what the you
know working in the retail space
whatever it is that helps you prepare to
work in a group dynamic
it's also being a good teammate that
allows everyone else to feel
like it's okay if they fail um and
that's where the greatest
ideas come from absolutely
um yeah as a manager like lots of times
it's it's it's
it's one of those things the more that
you can make it okay to fail
create a safe space for people to fail
um that's where you're going to get the
best ideas
also you're dead screaming at me
i have one complaint about this i have
no idea i was
i was in the room we started in launch
pad or something there is one task in
there that just slowly
yeah you can walk away you can leave you
can go away
i was wondering why you were standing
there felix
walk away well
unless anybody has any info i have no
clue who it is
oh where was it steffie i saw billy and
i want to say something
the chat before we started they were
like
free hill billy let's go billy
everybody in the shad was just like he
did die
immediately again
[Applause]
okay
this is the last round yeah
okay one one question for the group what
do you think is the biggest
misconception about working in the games
industry
it's not easy um
yeah i think that uh i think also just
like
getting used to not worrying about
making your magnum opus the first time
like i think
it's like you have to think about it in
terms of a marathon and you're going to
be working on multiple projects and i
think that a lot of people get caught up
in like
making the game uh but you gotta work up
to it
um david's dead in the cafeteria
damn it
i don't know i was going to the reactor
and i didn't see anybody else there when
i got there so
i was going to the reactor as well
wait alana called it yeah david's dead
in cafeteria
i haven't been that's all i have
that's all i have so david killed
himself because he was answering a
question
i'm really nervous because i don't know
if we've we haven't kicked anyone off
yet so i think we need to vote for
someone
yeah i have no idea i don't think
i don't think it's felix because they
were caught up with the dumb task
i've never found my life that was that
was ridiculous and the only person that
i was even suspicious of
was felix but i'm willing to give them
benefit of the doubt
i'm i'm suspicious between alana and
victoria
okay because i don't think it was like
excuse me i did you're taking too much
charge i voted for you i'm so sorry oh
my gosh
yeah i know i just did it
right you've been right before so i
would like to hear this logic
[Applause]
marlo is taking up it's sucking the air
out of the room because
and taking charges
it's true you're incredibly gracious
you're very gracious until you tend to
give the
strength give the floor to people and
then when you're there all i'm saying is
i trust felix that's all i have to go by
there
that's what happened
how are we doing on donations yeah
i'm about to say that but wait let me
let me just do one thing let me just do
one thing first
aloey because i think we're done with
the game
so let's go back to the other setup so
we can chat for
a couple of minutes if that's okay
because
before before we announce what's the
amount right now i just had two last
questions that i have from the chat
um one is have you have any of you
guys had to crunch a game
yes yeah i've not had to crunch a game
but i can tell you i crunched
constantly in games media
like my crunch was self-imposed it was
while i was doing freelance
so i was doing side projects while i was
working full-time on a game
um and i would not recommend it
uh yeah it it it really it really burns
you out and then you spend way more time
recovering than you you know would have
made up from crunching so in your output
avoid at all costs
i crunch a lot and it bites i'm also a
stress eater
and i'm a recreational eater
yeah it's so i gain weight like i'm
short too so it's like there's only so
many places fat can go
so you can easily
hardcore crunch mode like i in the past
couple years i've like easily gained 30
pounds to where my doctor was like
is it possible you're pregnant i'm like
i'm sorry is it possible i've just been
eating too much
no wow
she's my primary care doctor but i was
just like
oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah i've it's difficult because
like i've been at some
in-house studios where like i've had to
crunch like
for months and i'll work like 18 to 22
hours
on a game that you know i don't really
feel
so strongly about but you're in there
because all of your
other team members are working their
hardest and
it comes out it's not rated well and
then people review it and say like oh
they get the devs they're so lazy it's
like no
man we're working hard and i think what
people forget
is that sometimes it's out of the devs
control
about what happens in a certain
sometimes it's a publisher that has
certain things that they want you to
change in a game
or sometimes it's budgetary constraints
and
you know there's so many factors that
come into play so it makes me really sad
to see
fans sending hate mail to people and
harassing devs and and their families
like that is just so
great why friends like i feel like we're
i'm i'm like an old fart now like and it
makes me sad to think that
i'm from a generation where if you
didn't like something you just left it
and you move on
and now we have people that spend so
much of their time
writing novellas about how much they
hate something and how much they don't
like these devs or
a studio or why they're upset that
something's delayed and it's just so
disheartening
as a creative to see that kind of
and i think like that's interesting
because it goes into the
um in my field of work i think
like for a lot of community managers a
lot of social media managers we get into
a self-imposed crunch as like some of us
were talking about but like when you
have
all these people throwing hate at the
devs that you care for but you also
are part of the community and you always
communicate with them it's like
it feels like you can never turn off and
it feels like
if you're if you don't reply to their
massive amounts of tweets
and every single one of them then
suddenly like you become the bad guy and
like you
and you don't want that feeling and
because community managers have to like
kind of
have that in between space between
developers and their fans
like yeah yeah so it's like it's
i haven't i wasn't never forced to
crunch and i was very encouraged and i
was very lucky to be encouraged to like
take breaks and like don't worry about
it but it's like it's so hard because
games are something that you get into
because you're passionate about it's
your hobby and it's your job
and i think a lot of people end up
crunching themselves because
they're like but i love this game and i
want it to succeed and i want people to
enjoy the game i don't
want them to hate it um yeah you gotta
you have to love yourself more than your
games sometimes though you know like
that's yeah
that's the ticket like that's the rough
thing though because like if your
co-workers are
crunching it's like sometimes you have a
lot of sympathetic crunch too
yeah yeah that's like a that can fall
into you know a larger conversation of
like workplace culture can definitely
impose crunch a lot of the times and
that can feel out of your control
um depending on like where you work and
everything like that but if it is within
your power at all to avoid it or like
put yourselves in situations where you
can avoid it completely like
you absolutely have to do it because it
is a marathon like
you're not just working on one game and
once it's out the door you're never
working again like you're gonna move on
to another project because you have to
keep doing that
um so you don't wanna you know burn the
candle at both ends so you can't work on
the
game that comes after the one you're on
right now yeah ideally you'll have like
someone
within leadership that you can talk to
and can bring up like hey i'm i'm
i'm feeling burnt out i need help to get
this kind of sorted out
um and ideally if leadership is correct
and if man
management can move things around
properly we can mitigate that and that's
the
ideal scenario it's just it's really sad
because like i've been
at in-house studios and to be uh
to clarify like right now i'm doing a
lot of freelance work but i've been
in house studios where i've seen
marriages fall apart
and kids you know missing their parents
and spouses not believing that their
other spouse is
actually working at said hour it's like
ah it's so sad and you know
like you're saying we're we're just
passionate about what we need
to do to make this game successful and
to help our co-workers succeed in what
they're working on too
and like i wish i wish all fans could
see that too but i mean that's not they
don't have to like it's
not their responsibility to be like how
many
teardrops has felix cried over this
but it's still i wish i wish fans
respected
devs as much as we respect our fans and
our games that we work on
that's a great sentiment yeah really
hard thing to watch about crunch it's
like
watching people attack developers for
something that in theory in a lot of
cases is coming from leadership but also
you know i've known people who've been
so disheartened by
um attacks from the community when it
has come out that their studios are
crunching that they feel like all of
that hard work is like down the drain
and they're like i actually wanted to do
this which is not something a culture
should promote you should stop your
employees from crunching but um
it's it's very rough to watch the
response to crunch being like screw your
game and screw your studio rather than
like
i hope you're all okay um i'm sorry that
you're having to go through this the
lack of support is just it's very hard
for me to rationalize it's
it's really brutal you got a lot of
bunch of stuff
from the yeah yeah yeah and i think a
lot of it comes
from a misunderstanding of what game
development really is and game
development at the end of the day is a
series of decisions that were made by
very few people over the span of many
years and i think that that
you know if you make a decision four
years ago that it that causes crunch
today
it it's not like you made the decision
thinking [ __ ] my employees or [ __ ] my
team
or like screw everybody i work with i'm
gonna make this choice and it's gonna
result in them
you know a lot of the time crunches due
to a series of decisions that were made
over a long period of time that felt
like the right decision in the moment
and turned out to be
actually pretty pretty tough long term
you know and i think
that's not to excuse excuse like
management or culture that encourages
crunch it's just to say that
games are a long process and they're
very complicated process and you're
making decisions in the moment with the
most material you have in the moment
and a lot of the times that leads to
some some pretty tricky scenarios
overall and it's not that you know
everybody meant to
be where we are today if we're crunching
it just means that
a lot of game players don't understand
the game development process
and and not being able and i get why
because like you can't explain our jobs
if we could we could just
anybody could do them right like it's
like really hard to explain
every facet of game development in the
moment but it is
it is so tough to to see people jump to
that before
giving the benefit out in the moment to
a large group of people that are doing
the best they can with the resources
they have in the movie yeah i'd say that
like
scoping games is the most impossible
thing ever like
understanding understanding how long it
takes to make a video game no matter how
many games you make is
actually impossible it's like you're
throwing darts in the dark into another
room
through two closed doors like it's like
and david's
asking you questions at the same time
how you see your tasks in among us and
you're like that won't take me too long
and then it takes you
triple the amount of time you think it's
gonna take you yeah um
so yeah that can result in crunch a lot
of the times too or you think like oh
i'm gonna get this done in two years and
then you realize you actually are making
a three year long game
and then you've committed to a timeline
and a budget of two years so
uh games are a lot about compromise um i
think it's like
starting with the pie in the sky and
then working your way back a lot of the
times is what it feels like
so yeah that's why i think it's so
important to at least
have a safe environment
for everyone because then when you do it
with love and when you're
comfortable with it then you know
the process feels better yeah and you
were able to have the conversation
earlier right it's not just about like
they're being loved it's about the
the space to be able to bring it up
earlier and to be able to say
i think maybe we've we're in over our
heads right that space is so rare
and i think it's something that that
when you find it in a studio
you're doing it you're doing really good
so sorry uh i interrupted you i
apologize
really oh oh no it's i mean that's one
of the main things where it's like
you put a lot of effort into hiring
people
lots of times that one of the things you
talk about is
uh what is the culture of the studio
itself
and you have to have that knowledge you
have to understand what that is
and you hire into that you hire people
into it
that you know um are
on this journey with you that you can
build this level of trust and respect
um that helps it helps
ease the burden i mean because what we
it's a creative process i mean what we
make
is it's it is it's commercial art at the
end of the day but
it's still art and it's a creative thing
and if you really care
about making a game that people
will love that and that you love
yourself you test a lot
and like testing you discover so many
things like
you can work in games forever and then
find out that
you know like felix was saying a
decision you made two years earlier
is something that's just not resonating
and so then you're kind of like
what do you do do you keep pushing
forward in a direction that
may not be the best direction or do you
shift direction and
costing time and money yeah yeah
and then and then rely on the passion of
the people that you trust and respect
that you work with
to actually pull through and get it get
it done
like anybody that goes about the process
of trying
to make a game um in this you know
utopian sort of like setup it's
it's it's it's really hard and i'm not
saying it hasn't happened before
um i i but i've never experienced it
myself
but at the end of the day if you can if
you can ship a game
and you can look around at everybody at
the finish line
and you can kind of like say okay we did
this and we did it
with the game in mind and
the best interest of everybody that i'm
around because i trust and respect these
people
that's the best feeling in the world
yeah they're called yeah
they're all miracles that's true it's
just
every single one is a miracle you have
to think of it that way too yeah yeah
yeah okay so then to close this panel up
i just want you guys
in um as little words that you can
just tell me why do you love video games
alana you can start oh boy
um why do i love video games i've played
games since
you know for as long as i can remember
and uh
there are a million reasons but the the
shortest one for me is that
i'm someone who has a series of chronic
illnesses um i had really bad asthma
when i was a kid and like you know had
to go to hospital
um that's become more manageable in
later life but not by that much and i
feel like what i was doing
when i was um unwell or you know
couldn't necessarily be outside and go
running around with the other kids was
playing video games and having these
experiences that were full of color and
life and laughter and
um very fun that i feel like i
i would have been a different person if
i didn't have a that level of escapism
or be that kind of like rewarding
interaction where i felt like i was
accomplishing things all the time
um so i just feel like for you know the
kind of person that i am who like i now
a chronic illness i deal with can leave
me in bed for you know days on end
sometimes
and playing video games like the witness
or or braid um
anything that's like challenging me
mentally can really help
my mental health so i feel like you know
there are a million reasons i love video
games but to talk about the most
personal ones it's the um
the sense of accomplishment uh the
challenges and
the um i guess also storytelling of
course um and just rich vibrant worlds
that i could get lost in
when i can't really get lost in the real
world
that's so cool i just want to say i love
the witness
the winners helped me a lot when i had
pneumonia the first time like i thanked
that game for getting me through
pneumonia it was
it was the best so so tough but so
rewarding when i was just like on
codeine for two weeks it was great
yeah i don't want to talk about like
steffi's experience with the game but i
know like she suffers from
anxiety and like those types of games
like have helped her
a lot through several episodes so
yeah um felix
yeah i mean i love how flexible games
are in experience
accessibility and storytelling i think
that flexibility is
is like the most you know i
i have a really tough time with uh i
used to be a voracious reader
as a kid and then somewhere along the
line the way that adhd developed and my
anxiety developed over time
as an adult uh part of my coping
mechanism is
um not engaging with things that take up
a lot of my
my attention in a moment and video games
have taught me
uh brought me back from that in a lot of
ways they sort of like taught me like
it's okay to engage with something in
the way that you want to and there's
probably some form of that thing out
there for you you just have to go dig
for it and there's so many different
types
of video game and they're so flexible in
how they present themselves to you that
i think it's really tough to find maybe
every tv show you like or
every movie that resonates with you or
every right but like
because you are invested in the video
game and the fact that it gives back to
you in the same way that you give to it
where i find that other medias don't i
the fact that i can still play a game
for more than
10 minutes but i can't read a book for
more than 30 seconds is
really hurting me it means that maybe
there's a path back to like this
this sort of place where i can find calm
and resonance and
and interest and i think that
as an adult when you suffer
it's a little different than when you're
a kid and the
a lot of us grew up playing video games
as a cool thing and a lot of us
now use video games as a coping
mechanism and i think that is so
dope that is like the question
it's something that i don't hear in
other mediums as much but i think i hear
it
all the time in video games or coping or
escapism or
some form of healing right and i don't
know if i can be part of that in any way
i'm hoping to
someday you know like i'm hoping to be
able to say like i i partook in some
healing
process for myself for someone else and
i think video games are different in
that way definitely
marlow yeah i think uh i absolutely echo
the feeling
them is coping mechanisms and being able
to get lost in games i think for me as
an artist who
likes to you know focus on world
building and telling stories i think the
attraction for video games is that
they're in active media versus a passive
media
so by being able to actually have
players engage with the stories that
you're telling it makes them way more
potent
and it makes it you know more engaging
and i think that it's a really
powerful tool to tell positive stories
and have people engage with positive
stories and feel like they're part of
positive stories
um so that's what really inspires me
about them i think also just like as
someone who grew up
playing them and being inspired by them
i'm so excited that the
possibility that something i make
inspires a kid to get into being
creative or making games themselves
um i think that's that's the biggest
draw personally
victoria yeah i think this is based on
i mean my job being a community director
is that
what games why i love games so much is
that i find them to be
one of the best mediums for actual
connection
online i think we mistake a lot of the
time that you know because we can tweet
at someone or because like
yeah i have like a thousand facebook
friends that i'm connected with them but
that's not true right
it's the moments of like a lot of being
like i love the witness and
stephanie also being like i love the
witness and then like there's a
connection there and then
you can kind of build a relationship or
seeing chat like
sending all the hearts to steffi or like
rooting for billy i
i love the way that games create
moments where people from different
cultures from glo
like globally um can come together and
actually genuinely
have fun with each other and kind of get
on a level where they can start
interacting and talking and
understanding each other more and
connecting in a way that i think
i haven't seen any other medium really
do as well
okay thank you for getting the microsoft
i'm sorry
i think a lot of my answer mirrors um
answers that have already been said i
read a whole bunch as a kid
i was very much a lonely kid i
was i had a lot of restrictions about um
if i was able to go out and hang out
with friends even as
you know i got older and whatnot so
reading and playing video games was my
escape
and playing video games was great
because i'm the person that talks to
every damn npc i want to know their
story tell me what you had for breakfast
tell me your whole dialogue three like
i those were my friends like i played
i loved playing chrono cross i know
people hate it because there's so many
different routes and so many different
characters but i loved it because
i could go and make a whole bunch of
friends um
and you know it's same with what
victoria was saying with connect
connection
i haven't seen felix in quite a while
and when we started playing animal
crossing and
i noticed that their um their gate was
open and i went and visited i came in
with
like my little ocarina and played creepy
music while
felix was just laying in bed and it was
saying
saying me to sleep twice it was the best
and it's like i felt so connected in a
different sense that you know you kind
of don't have in
other medias um and very similar to the
other
stories like i i have chronic depression
and anxiety
and playing video games is such a great
way to
have an active way to keep your mind
busy
um and be hitting minor goals
like really tiny goals like in animal
crossing or
if you like playing fire emblem um
and decide that you're not gonna have
anyone in your crew die
and you have to redo your battle so many
times like yo it's such a great way to
keep your mind occupied
and still at the same time feel like
you're engaged with the world
um and helping out your friends like
dorothea yo
so i don't know i i love games um
i'm i'm so thankful to be a part of it
i'm so glad that i kind of
fell into um the realm that i was not
expecting like
sure i could have been like an asian
doctor wow but would i have purple hair
like
no and honestly i would never have
explored
creative routes and i'm so thankful
for for this industry in being a place
where i can make light bulbs
and have those light bulbs have sounds
of tigers mixed in with a slight fart
element to give it texture and it's
acceptable because no one knows
um i don't know i i love this community
and i hope that our community can
continue to grow
and be be open to each other and also
understand that we're all students
like there's so much we can learn from
people coming right out of school so
much we can learn from those
many years ahead of us and you know once
we stop looking at ourselves as a
student that's when we're really falling
behind and we're
damaging not only ourselves but our
community at large
wow that was so good
billy that was amazing
are we done yeah follow that i feel like
the short answer that i also want to add
is just video games are really fun and
cool
so yeah i think we are
like i was gonna make a game with geese
like wow yeah
no i i just i just love the fact that we
had
the usage of fart and texture in like
the same
sentence and it made sense to everybody
yes it's that city here you got juicy
fire you got dry fart you got airy fart
like they're all different textures
i just want to say something there's
there's we haven't had
one stream in our channel since we
started where we haven't talked about
farting
i did it i helped you you're welcome
there you go
there you go um yep or poop yep okay
billy you were saying
no so i i like i i got into i got into
games because of
escapism right like you know i grew up
in an era when
where the way that you could escape was
through
movies and then you know colecovision
came along i'm totally dating myself
but you know i i'm playing something
where it's i'm
interacting with it and i mean freaking
you know
pitfall harry you know he's just some
pixels but like
i'm like oh that's indiana jones you
know i'm i'm
coming and instead of having to play
with action figures
and make up my own stories you know for
how boba fett falls into the sarlacc pit
and i don't want him to fall in the
sarlacc pit so in my version
he doesn't fall in the sarlacc pit
because i'm boba fett
and
[Laughter]
the great thing about is there's this
there's this escapism but there's also
interactivity and then you know as a kid
the more and more i would play games
i kept on feeling like this is gonna go
this is gonna go so much further like i
i love movies growing up
and i love reading books and all these
are mediums where people are entertained
but this has this level
of immersion and agency that is
at the time for me it was like not it
was untapped and so the idea that you
could go
and do something and create something
where everybody comes out with a
different view of what the experience
was that they had
and they're the person that made it
happen but then
you know seeing steffy you know cry
when talking about witness like those
that's the amazing part about what it is
that we
do we can make people laugh we can make
people throw a controller and break it
you know oh my god help people through
divorces it's just
it's this amazing opportunity uh that
that i i wish i could say when when i
went into it
i i like i knew that this is where it
was gonna go i just knew that it was
going to go
somewhere different than what i had
already experienced
and you know and also get to work with
all the people that i get to work with
because everybody's so passionate about
this for a lot of the same reasons so
yeah yeah
whether you love video games oh my god
well everything they said i'm gonna give
such a good answer in english
but basically oh my god i've cried so
much
i'm just very happy i'm just very happy
right now
my chat is used to it i'm just prior
whenever i feel something very strongly
i cry and i'm very happy and grateful
right now
um could you could you answer the
question first thank you
um i think you made me cry so now we're
both here
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna take my answer to say
um i love video games because
most of my dearest friendships have come
from experiences on a video game um
um basically most of what you guys have
said
um the the idea of community that a game
creates
um either playing with somebody or
talking about the game with somebody
and i i truly believe even though we've
actually
talked about some of the uh misfortunes
of the community i do think
the video game community as a whole is
very inclusive and
and tries to to mend
people i mean we i think we have a
great community um we even have like a
channel in our discord where people just
go and vent
um and that's all on video games that's
all on the love that we all have for
them so i i
truly want to thank all of you for
creating experiences where
we actually can grow as a community and
as people and everything
and the second reason i and this is
where i'm going to cry
is because we made this event
around video games and um
our goal was to get to 2500
and we reached almost
and fifty dollars over our goal awesome
so thank you and truly thank you for
your time
i mean you guys are so sweet i clap in
spanish
i know i i know you haven't been able to
over i know you haven't had the chance
to read over the chat but basically the
last
15 minutes have been like all everyone
in the chat just
thanking you for your time saying what a
great opportunity this was what a great
closure to this whole event it was it
was
we've been working on this for months um
this is the biggest thing
we've done and having you guys just was
like the cherry on top
and um we had an original goal like of
2 500 so to be like almost
a thousand pennies over it it's like
amazing um congratulations you guys so
yeah i won't i won't i won't speak
anymore because then i'm gonna
be like really crying i'm just gonna i'm
gonna throw the ball to steffi that's
already crying
cry stream oh my god we're already
hearing um
yes i used to be ashamed of crying now i
just do it
anywhere everywhere all the time
it's an important physical reaction you
have to let those out you got to let
those tears out
holding them in is not good for you come
on
it's just like peeing you gotta pee
like there you go important answers
bye
[Music]
is
yeah it is i like it well for me i think
it was it was the same i think that's
why i cried and i think
that's why i felt so happy because i
just felt
um connected with all of you in some way
i just love that i can
escape for a moment and just be there
and enjoy it
and i love the indie industry because
it's
it has given me so many moments that i
can relate to
um that i just love just going online
and
just searching through see what design i
like
on the logo or whatever and i just try
it i don't care if it's free
or it costs 199 or 50 dollars i just
tried because
i think it can result with me and
in people in panama didn't used to know
in this that much
and now they're open to it and now just
people are
seeing i think they're
seeing themselves on video games now i
don't know
and they just create special moments
i know what i wanted to say i've been
trying to remember
the other day i wasn't feeling very good
i was having a lot of anxiety because of
something
something and i opened kind words i have
it right there
and i wrote and find words and then
the responses i got they got me so happy
and emotional
and just things like that i think
just having that moment where you're
yourself and it's
okay it's
so cool to see that hindi as an industry
opened up the idea of game streaming
really small
in addition to being really really big
because i think it gives us moments
that we can engage with versus
150 hours that we can you know what i
mean like i think that although big
games have those moments it's
so cool that even among us right we
played it tonight and how many
sessions did we play and the longest
session was 10 minutes or whatever it
was although it felt like
forever because the stuff you kept
killing us
but the point is like it's so cool to
see that we're able to have
to to turn to a whole medium for the for
the tiny moments as well as the big
sweeping
narrative like giant huge moments right
like we can get those little tiny
moments out of it too and i think
i don't know that's what i meant by
flexibility like i think that we all
we all are able to see that and that's
that's super dope that's new and it's
dope
games are dope on
another stream 29 minutes ago uh
at 6 00. but i didn't want to cut any of
this off you love us
um so thank you guys but i do have to
run so i don't let
the other people waiting for me yeah
we'll just we'll we'll close the the
stream right away too
so um alana thank you for your time
thank you for everything i think all of
you guys
are going to close stream
thank you alana thank you felix thank
you billy thank you cat thank you vic
thank you marlo hope to see you guys in
person
eventually in an event or something and
i have a drink or have something and i
really really really really really
appreciate you guys and your time thank
you so much
okay i'm streaming project winter now
everyone i may not do it with my my
webcam so they don't have to worry about
it i gotta eat
real quick and then we gotta play
project winter so